motif une faille faire vous avez
resplendit pendant les vacances vous
avez eu le temps de lire quand même ben
oui vous avez vu le soleil qu'il a fait
pendant ces vacances un livre soleil cet
idéal c'est pas mal c'est pas mal ce qui
est bien aussi ça serait de nous faire
le lien avec la rentrée scolaire qui a
eu lieu dès des rentrées qui sont
parfois un petit peu chaotique notamment
pour vous super-héros paraît-il et oui
c'est tout simple des héros d'affronter
cette rentrée justement figurez vous que
le premier livre c'est pour les enfants
qui n'aiment pas l'école comme peut-être
ces jeunes qu'on a vu qu'ils étaient
peut-être un petit peu fâchée avec
l'école quand il était jeune
ce livre là l'école maman et moi de
clotilde delacroix édité au seuil
jeunesse est un bijou et ça permettra
peut-être aux enfants de comprendre
pourquoi parfois on a du mal l'héroïne
figurez vous déteste l'école vous le
voyez pour y aller sa maman est obligé
de la motiver avec une carotte puisque
c'est un lapin elle finit même par aller
à l'école en choses sont tellement elle
est motivée c'est mignon je sais pas si
on voit là la légende bien marquer la
maîtresse aldi donc tu me dis que tu as
oublié ton cartable à la maison et puis
dessous c'est quelque chose
es-tu sûr que c'est le seul problème et
c'est pas franchement le seul problème
si on regarde supposé hama voilà les
achats d'or les petits chaussons
donc c'est un acte manqué un réveil elle
voulait vraiment pas y aller comme mon
fils ce matin qui était en pyjama
pendant un petit moment
voilà est doux mais en fait ce livre est
très drôle ya que des dessins comme ça
et on comprend que la mère non plus hein
elle n'aimait pas l'école parfois c'est
une histoire de famille donc je vous
conseille vraiment cet album qui fait
rire les enfants les parents à partir de
6 ans ça permet de discuter de l'école
ce qu'on aime ce qu'on n'aime pas ce qui
peut poser problème
c'est un vrai bijou alors j'adore
clotilde de la croix c'est toujours très
drôle très tendre et vraiment on rit à
chaque page
à partir de quel âge un bol six ans si
vous racontez l'histoire est bien plus
tard si vous savez lire déjà vous voyez
la mer voilà au niveau de jeu me tiens
bien sur ma chaise elle acquit tenir
cette petite petite fille qui s'est fait
disputer alors l'école ça fait souvent
rêver parfois ça fait cauchemarder aussi
attention
il ya quand même un petit village où vit
elvis et un hibou faut que vous m'en
parler parce que ça aussi c'est un
ouvrage sympa oui c'est la sortie de
cette année à l'école des loisirs
ça s'appelle l'école des sourds et une
rentrée en canoë d'agnès mathieu daudé
et marc boutavant alors figurez vous qu
elvis c'est un vieux hibou un peu
ronchon et se dit je vais ouvrir une
école comme ça les enfants vous y allez
je vais être tranquille et je vais
regarder ça du haut de mon perchoir
puisque je serai le directeur
évidemment vous imaginez que des enfants
à l'école ça ne devient pas sage
immédiatement il ne suffit pas de mettre
des tables des chaises pour faire une
classe et n'oublions jamais les chiens
font pas des chats ont aussi une part de
responsabilité
donc ça fait beaucoup rire les enfants
qui lisent le livre voilà de découvrir
ces adultes avec bien des illusions sur
l'école sur ce qu'ils vont réussir à
faire avec des enfants en l'occurrence
les enfants sont des souriceaux qui ont
tous des prénoms qui commence par w doha
bien figurez vous que c'est impossible
de tenir une classe dans ces conditions
à l'essai à partir de 8 ans et je le
conseille vraiment super j'espère que ça
va être possible pour vous en 30
secondes de m'en dire un petit peu plus
sur le dernier livre que vous avez
sélectionné avec apparemment une rentrée
qui est un petit peu plus appréhender
cette fois ci oui c'est un vrai coup de
coeur ça s'appelle l'incroyable histoire
du mouton qui sauva une école à la joie
de lire par thomas gerbault et pauline
kerleroux et je voulais vous en parler
parce que imaginer une école qui est
menacée de fermeture et qu'on l'apprend
le jour de la rentrée
alors pour la sauver on inscrit en
mouton pour compléter la classe ça
paraît loufoque mais ça s'est vraiment
produit et je vous conseille oui je vous
conseille vraiment cette histoire c'est
très beau les personnages sont hauts en
couleur et vraiment c'est un vrai coup
de coeur le titre
l'incroyable histoire du mouton qui
sauva une école super merci stephen fry
ferons mettra sur les réseaux sociaux et
tout ce qu'il faut
toutes les références de ces ouvrages
merci